l'avenir appartient à ceux qui ne se
lève pas
je tends une période d' approche fait
bravo pour ce soir c'était vraiment bien
terni sa tasse et a plu ouais ok ça
serait bien qu'on la cour là travaillent
ensemble ensemble tous les deux
dias enfin oui je veux bien mais
carrément bah ouais carrément tr ois
super écoute j'ai tout numéro t'as qu'à
m'appeler boum on s'organise à on sait
ça ah ben non c'est à mon numéro tu
m'appelles toi c'est plus simple oui
mais non encore mieux beaucoup plus plus
malins oui bien sûr une évidence puisque
je t'aime du coup je t'appelle et puis
voilà suivant décroche oui ou non tué
quand les oilers et les granges parce
que c'est comme si sans je veux pas trop
me immiscé dans la meilleure vague mais
chacun est libre
du coup donc moi s'est il est aussi bon
sens non mais je suis en scooter tu veux
te défonces pause posée tu veux aller
pause je pense que tu es toujours des
bonnes sensations en scooter ça te
permet j'ai pas de casque [ __ ] à grave
je vais
si je rentre à tout ça mais ouais